pour soir nous sommes le 17 mars
2026 je me prépare pour aller fêter la
saint-patrick avec quelques amis donc en
fait comme jeanne célébrer mon
anniversaire je suis maintenant
quelqu'un génère je me suis dit que
j'étais en bonne santé mais c'est
important de le rester donc aujourd'hui
j'ai réalisé un interview avec mon
médecin une interview au rendez vous
pour préparer ce rendez vous j'avais
pris soin men évidemment très
régulièrement surveiller ma santé avec
en vérifiant que je n'avais pas de
diabète que je n'avais pas de
cholestérol que chip en surpoids que
m'attend sur va bien donc tout va bien
mon hygiène alimentaire j'ai un coup tu
vis avec ma petite application toutes
ces données là ont été transmises à mon
médecin et j'ai fait un skype avec lui
tout à l'heure parce que quand même
c'est beaucoup plus simple revenons
maintenant en 2016
vous savez mon problème le manque en
fait la moyenne d'âge des médecins et 54
ans donc en 2026 on aura à 95% des
masses un trentenaire qui seront des
digital natives qui seront nés et qu'ils
ont grandi qu'ils ont appris leur métier
avec tout simplement tous ces objets
connectés toutes ces applications et qui
en feront dans leur quotidien un outil
de travail est un outil de gestion de la
relation avec le patient pour
l'accompagner pour améliorer tout ça est
en fait c'est déjà le cas aujourd'hui
parce que c'est des choses qui sont
maintenant moins tabou qui sont
développés dans les villages on accepte
d'être connecté on accepte que nos
données soient partagées et puisse être
analysées et ce qui ressort de tout ça
c'est que en fait 30 à 50 % des
traitements qui sont prescrits pour des
pathologies chroniques ne sont pas
appliquées correctement
donc ces patients là ne sont pas traités
et peuvent continuer à souffrir de ces
maladies
a contrario
peut-être 20 ou 30% des traitements qui
sont prescrits ne sont pas utiles et
peuvent même être dangereux pour la
personne qui le reçoit ce traitement
donc bon an mal an on arrive à peu près
à 30 % de gain potentiel des dépenses de
100 sur les dépenses de santé par
rapport à ce que et qui est prescrit
aujourd'hui et tous les frais qui sont
engagés et en fait tout ça ça correspond
aussi à des montants conséquents et un
soin que un vrai malade peut avoir chez
soi ça s'appelle la télémédecine 1 c'est
que plutôt que de faire des kilomètres
d'être hospitalisés alors que la
situation ne nécessite pas pouvoir
rester chez soi avoir un support on va
dire par le corps médical qu'il soit
approprié qui soit moins intrusif et
puis un accompagnement par la famille ou
tout simplement des gens qui sont en
bonne santé et qu'ils peuvent avoir une
fragilité peuvent être surveillées
également typiquement et à une
application aujourd'hui déjà qui permet
de surveiller quelqu'un qui présente une
faiblesse cardiaque et d'anticiper un
accident cardiaque et de le traiter en
amont donc on est dans le préventif pour
le predictive et non plus dans le
curatif
donc certes moins juin je suis en mode
santé mais si on reprend un exemple le
rapport à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure de quelqu'un qui est une vraie
maladie qui a besoin de soins ne serait
ce qu'un homme qui a atteint 1 qui
atteint d'un cancer de la prostate un
skype mensuel avec son médecin qui aura
reçu au préalable ses analyses
biologiques suffit effectivement il aura
besoin d'être accompagné pour l'os
entraînement pour gérer sa douleur parce
qu'effectivement c'est des vrais
questions mais finalement si peu rester
à son domicile dans son quotidien avec
ses amis et conserver une vie être
entouré de ses proches
on sait aussi que c'est très important
pour eux la réussite de la thérapie par
ailleurs toute cette tente est connecté
on le sait bien en particulier si je
reprends le sujet du cancer
aucun cancérologue n'est en capacité de
traiter les vingt mille milliards de
données qui sont nécessaires pour vers
l'analyse génétique d'une tumeur c'est
juste pas possible et pour faire cette
analyse il ya des arbres de décision sur
des millions de branche
aucun cancérologue aucun médecin ne peut
le faire donc tout cela est traité par
des algorithmes par des mathématiciens
qui ont construit ces algorithmes qui
prépare et qui aide le praticien le
spécialiste dans son domaine d expertise
pour prendre la bonne décision
construire le bon traitement mais
finalement c'est vrai que ce chirurgien
il est pas mathématicien c'est pas lui
qui construit ses algorithmes ses
algorithmes ils ont besoin d'être
structuré réglementé piloter des idées
avec une certaine éthique et tout ça ça
nécessite aussi d'être travail et donc
son être le médecin son travail c'est
d'accompagner le trait le patient de
diagnostic et de le traiter et
finalement son métier c'est pas d'être
mathématicien c'est pas être un homme ou
une femme de loi c'est pas d'être
informaticien non plus mais si on avance
aussi sur d'autres thématiques on
parlait tout à l'heure de télémédecine
l'hôpital a aussi du vrai gain
potentiellement avec le numérique
si on reprend des sujets qui sont un peu
connexes certes mais qui sont très
structurant pour une bonne gestion d'un
hôpital
c'est la logistique c'est les équipes
financières et des logisticiens qui sont
particulièrement performants maintenant
l'occupation des lilas rotation des
patients les flux des patients dans les
hôpitaux c'est des vrais questions
il ya des spécialistes qui ont développé
des pratiques particulièrement
performante qui peuvent aussi soutenir
le corps médical dont l'évolution de la
vie dans l'ain dans un hôpital de la
même manière pour la gestion des stocks
des médicaments de la même manière pour
la gestion du la maintenance des
équipements qui sont très pointus et qui
sont nécessaires
pour le bon traitement de tous ses
patients avec des données qui sont
collectés qui sont sécurisées et tout ça
pour pouvoir offrir le meilleur soit
impossible et le plus sécurisé possible
pour ceux qui ont besoin de ces
traitements en particulier une pratique
un petit peu décalé qui se développe de
manière très performante
c'est dans le cas des hôpitaux si on
reste dans ce domaine là l'utilisation
de caméras pour un chirurgien qui est en
train de réaliser une intervention sur
un patient sur quelqu'un qui a besoin
d'être opéré et qui maintenant utilisent
sa caméra
les internes plutôt que d'être à côté et
d'observer petit à petit ils ont des
lunettes de réalité virtuelle
ça leur permet de voir de manière très
précise et avec les commentaires du
praticien expérimenté qui est en train
de réaliser l'acte finalement quel est
le geste et de ceux de se projeter comme
s'ils étaient en train de le faire et
ils acquièrent beaucoup plus facilement
avec beaucoup plus de précision et de
qualité le geste qui vont être amenés à
réaliser par la suite
dans un cas un petit peu plus décalé
mais finalement si on transpose c'est
quelque chose qui est envisageable et
qui est envisagé maintenant c'est que
dans des situations un peu plus extrêmes
si on parle de deux catastrophes
naturelles que ce soit par exemple un
tremblement terre quand il y en a eu
malheureusement quelques enfin 2015 que
ce soit pakistan que ce soit en inde
dans ces situations extrêmes les
compliqué d'avoir des expertises qui
viennent qu'ils soient disponibles
qu'ils soient au bon endroit au bon
moment
avec un tel casque de réalité virtuelle
guidé par un praticien qui est
spécialiste dans un domaine on peut
réaliser une intervention
et comme en même temps maintenant on va
les impressions 3d l'imprimante 3d nous
permet de concevoir imprimé en direct
une prothèse prothèse demain pour
quelques dizaines d'euros mais des
organes aussi des médicaments des
cellules souches qui concerne leurs
caractéristiques
tout cela ouvre beaucoup de portes et
pas facilite pas ce qu'il doit y avoir 5
milliards de personnes qui ne
bénéficient pas des actes chirurgicaux
du fait de compétences et de proximité
pour les réaliser donc en fait oui le
numérique apporte aussi toutes ces
spécialisations là tout ce potentiel là
dans le quotidien et pour les pratiques
alors là aussi c'est vrai que les
organes imprimé par une imprimante 3d il
ya des choses à réglementer à organiser
parce que quel est le contrôle qualité
cantonner à des l'autre bout du monde ou
qu'on avait quelque chose de spécifique
en cas d'urgence quelle est la garantie
par rapport aux produits qui a été
construit qu'elles aient l'assurance par
rapport aux praticiens qui est en train
de réaliser l'acte puisque il réalise un
acte qui peut être très lourd
chirurgicalement et finalement c'est
aussi sa responsabilité qui est engagée
dans tout ça ça pose beaucoup de
questions il ya beaucoup de travaux qui
sont en train d'être conduit et la
technologie avance très vite et tout ce
cadre réglementaire et éthique aussi il
doit avancer un rythme qui bouscule
beaucoup de deux structures que nous
avons déjà construites au cours de ces
dernières centaines d'années rien que ça
et finalement quelle pourrait être la
santé 3.0 bon j'aurais pris l'exemple
d'une voiture alors une voiture c'est un
petit peu le contraire que le corps
humain a quand même c'est à dire qu'une
voiture il ya 20 ans on pouvait tout
changer soi même mois tels que vous
voyez j'ai changé les pneus
bon je sais pas changé moi même les
pneus puisque j'ai pas crever une
voiture mon pneu c'est pas vrai et puis
on m'a aidée par contre j'ai changé moi
même le cadre de l'accélérateur
le câble de l'embrayage la tête de delko
essayer maintenant par contre de changer
une ampoule de le clignotant sur votre
voiture
essayez c'est juste inaccessible une
simple ampoule séparé par contre il ya
20 ans était extrêmement compliqué et
peu d'opérations était réussi
malheureusement pour le cas de grève
cadre d'une opération de prothèses
c'était quelque chose extrêmement lourd
et compliqué en termes de rééducation de
réussite etc
aujourd'hui on voit bien que
potentiellement
je me casse le veut nous demain au ski
je peux faire c'est mon genou je
caricature mais à peine finalement et
puis si dans trois ans je me replace au
genou mais potentiellement je me
recherche conjoint et puis peut-être
dans 50 ans je ré édition qui commençait
à diminuer
je me ferais greffer prothèse avec un
objet connecté kim augmentera parce que
finalement tout sera possible et à
souhait un volonté finalement pour le
confort pour des questions de santé
finalement est-ce que nous serons des
humains augmenté la seule chose en fait
dans ce parallèle c'est que ya 20 ans il
ya trente ans mais encore aujourd'hui
maintenant si le moteur de votre voiture
cass on change pas le moteur de la
voiture on change la voiture c'était le
cas ça l'est toujours
demain si on peut changer toutes les
pièces du corps humain est ce qu'on
pourra changer le cerveau parce qu'en
fait le cerveau c'est l'essence de
l'être humain est ce qu'on pourra le
faire écouter
il ya beaucoup de progrès en ce moment
parce que effectivement avec
l'augmentation de l'espérance de vie les
maladies du cerveau peuvent appeler sa
démence c'est tout simplement parkinson
alzheimer se développe considérablement
en 2030 25% la population européenne
aura plus de 65 ans est une vraie
question de société il ya une recherche
très forte qui se fait sur ces domaines
avec une progression qui peut être un
peu inquiétante et générait des
questions de société d'éthique
finalement jusqu'où pouvons-nous aller
parce que l'éthique mais a augmenté
commencerons nous finalement est-ce que
nous serons toujours des êtres vivants
ou est-ce qu'on nous aura à substituer à
d'autres choses je veux juste une
parenthèse
l'objectif du corps médical ça a
toujours été de soigner d'accompagner
les patients le plus humainement
possible
de réduire les méfaits de la maladie les
impacts la souffrance et lorsque plus
rien n'est possible
accompagner dignement la fin de la vie
leur objectif aux médecins et aux
pharmaciens à tous les chercheurs ça n'a
jamais été de tuer la mort mais
finalement tuer la mort c'est ce que
cherche à faire google parce qu'ils sont
et comme vous le savez probablement et
mène des recherches très poussées on
parlait tout à l'heure du cerveau sur le
transhumanisme la singularité on parle
aussi des nbic c'est un acronyme jolie
et nanotechnologies nanotechnologies
biotechnologies intelligence
artificielle et sciences cognitives
tous ces domaines là convergent vers un
homme augmenter il va augmenter qu'ivre
à milan autant dire l'éternité
finalement on s'est passée la planète
pourra nous accueillir nourrir tous mais
c'est quelque chose qui est
potentiellement accessibles et sous peu
de temps les personnes de google dix la
personne qui vivra milan est déjà né nos
enfants là peut-être vont-ils milan
après ce sont aussi des choix et
dynamique aussi bien intellectuel qu
humaines et sociétal des choix qu'il
faut arriver à conduire jusqu'où
pouvons-nous aller avec les travers
aussi bien c'est une quête du graal un
millénaire et qui peut à part ça valait
être à portée de main pour demain mais
aussi avec des déviances et un hulk qui
n'est plus un être humain et qui n'a
plus grand chose à voir avec un être
humain même s'il a des super pouvoirs
finalement donc cette santé 4.0 qu'est
ce que ça peut être la médecine du futur
ce que nous allons vivre
nous revendiquons le droit d'avoir de
pouvoir vivre plus longtemps de pouvoir
vieillir de pouvoir vieillir et de
pouvoir être heureux de pouvoir être en
bonne santé
tout cela passe par un équilibre
personnel un équilibre social par le
rire par le bien-être
j'évoquais tout à l'heure les les
maladies du cerveau
la démence on sait aussi que typiquement
des recherches qui sont menées ont
montré que les serious games on parle de
jeux vidéo ça permet de simuler les
cerveaux de garder un lien social et
finalement nous rendre heureux et
d'accompagner les personnes qui sont
plutôt de troisième âge voire quatrième
âge qui ont ces questions-là retraités
et pour pouvoir leur permettre d'être
connecté actifs intégrés et aussi de
rire et du bonheur donc finalement moi
je suis convaincu que la médecine de
demain la médecine du futur
ça va être aussi une médecine qui va
être humaniste qui va être respectueuse
qui va être une médecine orienté vers le
bonheur parce que on peut être augmentée
est ce que pour autant on a plus de
talent peut-être pas est ce qu on a
beaucoup plus de bonheur
certainement pas donc la clé la médecine
de demain pour moi ça sera la médecine
humaniste et du bonheur je vous remercie